[Music]
in parenting myth news submitted by that
fan a psychologist suggests that the
idea behind maternal instinct is a big
lie oh let's hear this psychologist
psychologist they're [ __ ] dumb dude
I graduated with psychology the
psychologists are stupid my degree but
keep going alright so are they dumb or
full of [ __ ]
both okay every single one huh
especially Freud [ __ ] Freud are you
saying Dodge's huh
don't they hate psychiatry what
Scientology - okay yeah keep going keep
going I'll talk about this later okay so
this psychologist is based in New York
there I was full of [ __ ] already
yes so she says that parenting skills
aren't instinctual or genetic parenting
skills yeah that there are learned and I
agree actually same yeah so they're
saying that sorry dude
that love is innate so mothers and
fathers love their children as deeply as
the other one right Oh only one maybe
it's like you don't need to be a
psychologist to know that [ __ ] so what
the psychologist is saying is that the
whole concept of like primal mama bond
gives dad's an out and so there's this
unfair division of child-rearing
responsibilities and so they're saying
that mothers do 65% of the child care
and fathers are only 35% and that's
according to the US Bureau of Labor
Statistics so wrong I do like 10% I do
the percentages like this is 64%
difference right like whatever I don't
know I'm just
yeah they're scientists they're [ __ ]
watching them work and I'm like or maybe
there's surveys and then like the
parents of mom so yeah then maybe the
dad role how many hours baby
because in most cases right yeah you
have a stay-at-home mom in most cases
yeah so it's like duh she's gonna have
more time with the know if nowadays
there is more stay-at-home moms though
mm-hmm statistically I think it's still
even now it is it's so big still
majority it might have shrunk but it's
still not 50/50 yeah maybe not an L not
know this but if you go to like Midwest
it's that's still a lot it's still stay
at home or even in big even in big
cities so according to a clinical
psychologist it's still like a larger
spread towards like moms moms yeah yeah
but like you guys said it isn't as
direct drastic as it used to be because
they're saying that it used to be an
80/20 split in the 70s and 80s yeah so
now it's the 6535 so that means dads are
being more involved yeah yeah more than
before
yeah 10 percent good job killing it dude
my brother he has he's about to have a
second kid and he's like sometimes I
come home and I'm like I can't wait to
go to the bathroom and try to act like
I'm taking the biggest thanks oh yeah I
guess I wanna have a kid now appreciate
it
I'll be his kid his kid is almost 2 okay
I get it yeah it's really I get it he's
very normal when I come home and I
looked at Jesus face sometimes she looks
red and so the minute I see her I'm like
type of red dress I'm like all right
come and I try to like just give them
all my attention but the next 3 hours so
at least she could just chill and relax
I know one hour cuz you come home at
7:00 all the time he goes to bed at 8:00
so it's ok I try to come home a little
bit earlier if I can okay Bart told me
he's like don't text me after 7:00 yep
be family time it's family time for
exactly one hour and you [ __ ] texted
him at 6:57 he's all my texts and for me
yes
so the psychologist here she's just
exploring how you know men are like dads
they should also take on more of the
child-rearing rolled and not just chalk
it up to oh you just got mommy instincts
because that's not a thing
a parent who does that a lot of people
my dad uh so my dad uh whom I love with
all my heart and soul he never held any
one of us as babies cuz he was just so
nervous with it and it was more like
well that's a well that's the woman's
job Oh a man holding a baby like that is
weird
yeah him he was just like that's like
I'm pretty sure it came from his own
insecurities and I froze and just from
him just being scared and not
understanding that whole thing where it
was like he didn't help he didn't hold
us that way until we could start walking
dude I been there man cuz either I've
held some babies before and felt like oh
man it's so small and delicate yeah I
don't want to drop just me too
I was there we feel that - yeah and her
and her dad also never even changed a
diaper right so so before like you know
like [ __ ] I would go like your fonts if
I'm spending the day at home her mom
would just come and go let me change the
diaper I'm like why Oh men don't do
these things I'm like I do it I'm like
I'll do it and then even so for her she
was like well this is a welcome weird
this is news a weird dynamic I'm like
call me a [ __ ] if you want I want to
change this diaper do dogs change never
say eight years old cuz I had little
brothers and [ __ ] and my mom you know I
can't do it
first of all I held my niece at the
bowling alley and she projectile peed
all over my rib cage I threw my shirt
away and everything but the diapers
laughter what did you stay yeah we had
today we like just got there my mom
liked me
he's the kick off my cows awful but I
always want I'm babysitting I let my mom
do the diaper change like I can't do
like the a swiping and like I all that
wears me out too and it's not your kid
like I don't want to clean other kids at
like I don't see a dirty diaper and I'm
like oh boy I can't wait do that no
that's true
when I was a kid I liked watching my
nephews like get changed because they
would pee and I thought it was so funny
when like the they would just pee it and
then my cousin has to hurry up and like
cover it yeah yeah yeah yeah it's it's
funny it's like a hot potato
I knew yeah what was I like ten I
couldn't agree with this article more
and I know you're against it because
they're stupid and whatever but I think
it's yeah I wasn't like you're not like
I got pregnant I didn't just get all
these like magical [ __ ] formulas like
in my mind where I'm like oh [ __ ] that's
how you do it like they make League made
me cuz I I thought the way that though
the title was I thought they were just
saying that maternal things as just bull
is just it's just not real like maternal
instincts isn't real at all that's kind
of what I am also receiving from this
yeah is that maternal instincts doesn't
exist they're all so confusing the words
I think I think there's maternal skills
yeah and maternal instincts for me I
think maternal skills you learn those
for sure but there is a certain like
instinct that I can see because Tycho's
been in her for like nine months yeah
that she is just way more in tune with
the guy since day one and I think it's
based right the way I view maternal
instinct is more survival so I don't see
it as like oh women are just better like
teaching children I see it as like women
see danger more than men can or a
different type of being right and then
so for survival like I think just in
general women are more they have empathy
empathy and they can see that the child
is thirsty or know that cry means I need
a change or whatever where maybe guys
would know but we don't spend as much
time with kids and our levels of what we
view as danger isn't
as much as you have to be working so I
guess you don't develop those instincts
yeah women do but so this psychologist
psychologist she said that she
discovered that within herself and a lot
of her other friends like she didn't
feel like she had those mommy instincts
and so does she give an example of does
she have me think yeah yeah she has two
girls oh I'm so she saying let me see
not really more like um cause like I
wouldn't be surprised if like Tiger
bangs his head right and he's crying if
there was a test and he came and to me
and I try to console him versus if Nikki
did it that he rates Nikki higher than
me hmm
and Nikki doesn't even have a kid it's
just there's these maternal instincts
that like they just see the emotion they
don't empathize they go iti kind of know
what this emotional being wants we're I
think because a lot of dudes are so
logic same thing between Nikki things
David beat Nikki I think Nikki would be
Steve I think so okay there's just a
different level of emotional
communication that I lot of guys were
like maybe like work boys are cut Israel
whatever but if he moms which is later
doesn't matter there's a cut I'm gonna
just make sure you feel safe aside I
also think that I pay attention one of
the normal people do normal guys do yeah
just because I just do that already
because I'm an observed observant person
yeah Nikki would say I'm not observant
but I'm observant of people so but but
the point being is like Nikki can just
sit there and play with a kid for three
and a half hours and never think about
anything else she's just playing with
the kid
and I am like I could observe needs and
things but then I'm like I'm like this
is getting boring
wait hear that I'm getting from this
psychologist is like not necessarily
focusing on the maternal instinct part
but the scales being that it's not even
the skills is saying like the the duties
like men don't have to do as much duties
because there's this belief that women
have more of a maternal instinct and
that's like an unfair division no I
think that's that's [ __ ] I think
there's also a secret in guy society
that we don't talk about much but we
pretend not to be able to do things so
they just will just do them I know
you guys have my know this but I don't
think that you guys know this 24/7 365
when we get away with it like [ __ ]
bandits
yeah like the washing machine you know
it's like the buns are made for female
fingers I'm like homeland press it it
doesn't even really water cold for
clothes I don't know am I talking about
straight culture it sounds like a
goddamn mess not like this like the
games and I mean I don't have kids but I
would assume we adopt or whatever it's
just gonna be equal like we're not gonna
be worried about when it was because I
don't we don't have to worry about that
we're just you would think so cuz I
heard so listening to this podcast when
our relationship was kind of bad and
they talked to this this lesbian couple
where they were gonna fix our problems
no no no so I was just listening to
different relationships and their
problems and then it's kind of like a
fly on the wall type thing and then so
yeah one of them took on the role of
like I guess the more mom where the
other one was I guess the more dad in
like the way that this psychologist is
describing it and and one felt like she
was underappreciated and and she was
always at home taking care of the kids
while the other one wasn't as involved
in stuff so I was just like oh in some
sort of like cortical gender role yeah
that's crazy yeah so interesting I throw
what it's called it's really just he's
more interested exactly thinking like
how does that it just sounds just I
would I would hope that my ideal partner
both they're 5050 yeah you don't feel
like one was more like or talk to them
see if that's actually the case
Kingsley's are you ever as interested as
somebody else in something I think
people have different interests and
things and that can include kids
sometimes so I think that just there's a
natural thing we're like Nicki's way
more in our cats than I am and like you
and I mean and I'm Way more into like
you know hanging out than she is and I
also think between the genders too
there's other things that they value
more or will take over more so like you
know guys might teach the kid like
fishing or [ __ ] hanging like whatever
you know
I mean it's not that women can do it but
it's maybe they're not as into it so
then moms can teach this way and dads
could teach this way and create a
balance that way yeah